Whoopi Goldberg has a theory as to why
certain Republicans voted for this
radical act that Beyond whatever you
think about marriage that's almost
secondary to what this act does the ACT
prohibiting the practice of Christianity
and Judaism and Islam and reasonableness
in an important way in the Public Square
here's Whoopi's Theory as to why some
Republicans went along with it
anytime somebody decides that they want
to get married celebrate that yeah
celebrate that don't tell them that
they're it's like Jim Crow laws voting
for that because you're giving the
finger to lots of married couples and I
suspect many of these folks voted the
way they did because somebody they know
said if you don't vote this way I'll
never speak to you again perhaps a lover
maybe a friend
wait what do you catch that at the end
she goes yeah it's because these
Republicans people in their lives told
them that if you vote this way I'll
never speak to you again and maybe that
person's a lover
maybe these Republicans maybe they have
gay lovers secret gay lovers and they're
gay lovers we're going to be really
upset with them if they didn't vote for
this
tihihih so I don't I don't think look I
don't particularly care for Mitt Romney
he drives me up a wall I don't think the
guy's got a gay lover I don't think
that's why he voted for this stupid bill
okay the same with these other people
who voted for it
but this is always where the the libs go
they say if you oppose their agenda if
you if you think that drag queens
shouldn't go read stories to
kindergartners say well why is it
because you're secretly gay huh which is
kind of funny because on the one hand
the libs are saying there's not
absolutely nothing wrong with being gay
it's actually the most wonderful thing
in the world everybody should be gay and
then on the other hand they're saying
yeah what are you are you a gay like
it's an insult you know yeah if you ever
disagree this word call you gay which is
really wonderful and it's the most
wonderful thing in the world except when
you do it you gay guy you dumb gay
person you're like like they're you know
in fourth grade on the playground so
there's a little bit of a contradiction
you might even call it homophobic if you
ask me but let's just go with Whoopi for
a second
let's say that this is why certain
Republicans voted for because they all
they all have secret gay lovers
that that part is is probably not true
but everyone does have something you
know everybody's got to pass everybody's
got skeletons everybody's done plenty of
bad things that they're ashamed of and a
lot of it is a sexual because man is
such a sexual being but some of it's not
sexual maybe it's a financial fraud
maybe it's uh some other kind of
political Scandal maybe it's a Family
Matter maybe it's whatever it is a good
reminder
that you should live a clean life you
should Endeavor to live the cleanest
life you can
because it's good for your soul and it
will be conducive to your salvation in a
virtuous Society
but also because your enemies want you
to live dirty and they want you to live
dirty because it can entrap you
because they can blackmail you because
they'll have dirt on you okay this is
one of the oldest tricks in the book
in the in the darker corners of politics
Espionage a political blackmail all of
it you you have these kind of Honey Pot
operations where you try to get a guy to
cheat on his wife or you try to get a
guy to take a bribe or you try to get a
guy to just do something dirty and you
do it because that will give you an
upper hand on them and we're living in a
world right now that is defined by data
increasingly companies and governments
are just getting every
ounce of data that that you possess
they're prying it out of you without you
even knowing it they're monitoring your
eye movements on your phone to see what
you're looking at when you're scrolling
up and down social media apps I think
this is in large part why the
instant powerful institutions in our
culture are pushing pornography on
people I think it's because it
compromises people I think it's because
it gives everyone such a sense of Shame
and fear and blackmail that that they
they just acquiesce it gives
the people
who are in power even more power it's no
different than J Edgar Hoover running
the FBI getting dirt and compromise on
people it's no different than the KGB
getting compromise on people and so you
you've got to be aware of that just in
your personal life this is how they
think
they think yeah well we're going to tell
people about your gay lover yeah we're
going to tell people that all your dirty
habits yeah if you don't go along with
us it is what it has always been
method of of gaining more control
whenever you are connected to an
unencrypted internet Network on your
phone computer tablet or TV you are
sending countless pieces of information
out into the digital world that can be
seen and intercepted by pretty much
anyone a VPN or virtual private Network
creates a secure tunnel between your
device and the Internet it's like
putting your postcard in an envelope so
that no one can read your letter before
it gets to the person that you're
sending it to expressvpn is the VPN I
trust to keep my data secure expressvpn
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
the hackers can't steal your data your
passwords your financial details just
fire up the app click one button it's
super duper easy you are instantly
protected plus expressvpn works on all
your devices so you can stay secure on
the go secure your online activity today
at expressvpn.com michaelenoll's show
get three extra months free that is
expressvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com slash Michael Knowles
show
speaking of disordered sexuality a Sam
Brinton the lipstick stiletto wearing
doggy leather
Leading Men around on a leash guy from
the Department of energy
he's been arrested and he's got a mug
shot out there and he looks a lot more
normal in the mug shot than he ever did
in his office at the department of
energy
I've got an unpopular opinion
this is unpopular so don't I'm giving
you fair warning
I feel sorry for Sam Brinton
I actually feel sorry for the guy
uh yes he's left of Lenin yes he seems
to be a huge liar yes he he seems to
have made up a lot of his biography the
center of his political biography is
that
he was subjected to conversion therapy
as a child you know that thing that
doesn't exist it was conversion therapy
and his awful parents tried to make him
not be gay or
transgender or into the leather puppy
costumes or whatever he's into and
that's what set him on his political
Journey but that story started to fall
apart because he wouldn't mention who
this evil Doctor Who tortured him was he
he then got really fuzzy on the details
and he said it actually happened in his
20s not when he was a child or a
teenager and even lgbtq Nation
obviously a left-wing publication has
admitted okay this guy's story really
doesn't check out but I really feel
sorry for Sam Brinton because he's
obviously deeply mentally ill he's
obviously got all sorts of problems and
disordered desires and that's true of a
lot of people it's no excuse necessarily
for just totally bad depraved Behavior
except for this
in the past when people had mental
illnesses and disorders and delusions
and weird desires and stuff the culture
the society
would try to help that person would try
to treat some of those illnesses would
would try to dispel some of those
delusions would try to give these people
therapy proper therapy that would say no
you're not really a woman you're a man
no you shouldn't you shouldn't drag men
around on leashes and weird leather
costumes no you don't wear lipstick boys
don't wear lipstick that's wrong unless
you're David Bowie take the lipstick off
no you no men don't wear the stiletto
heels no men you're a man and what that
means is certain things and you're
supposed to dress this way and do this
kind of thing and that's going to give
you a better life
and in our culture what happened was
exactly the opposite
in our culture
every single delusion and disorder
desire that Sam Brinton has ever had
been affirmed and celebrated by the
culture
we know who he is because he engages in
all these kinds of crazy Antics and puts
them all over social media and give us
lectures about all of his bizarre
disordered sexual desires and how much
he loves indulging them and he gets
celebrated by The Establishment media
for it and he's he's
put up as an icon of civil rights and
inclusivity
I promise you had this guy not just
gotten arrested for stealing women's
clothing and Luggage he would have been
at that White House ceremony Joe Biden
probably would have mentioned him by
name
because the Administration has put him
forward as a symbol of transgender and
so I just I feel bad for the guy because
he's been abused by Society
it has been criminal neglect and
negligence that our society has engaged
in with regard to this guy and with
regard to so many other people
when when the crazy purple-haired people
show up at my lectures and scream at me
about how I'm not respecting trans pans
dual Spirit rights or whatever I I have
a great deal of pity for them because
very often these are young people and
and they have been indulged
since the time they were five years old
and they've been groomed frankly by
their by their Educators in many cases
and so it's not their fault
exactly it's not their fault they're
they were raised in this way where in
the old way you'd be raised to Tamp down
your base passions and cultivate your
higher reason and your rational will
today it's exactly the opposite we're
told don't trust your higher reason
we're told that your moral conscience is
a liar we're told that the institutions
that once formed good normal flourishing
people they're all evil forget them all
you should do is indulge your your
appetites you should we should be fat
positive you should never stop eating
you should indulge gluttony you should
be sex positive you should cultivate
your lusts the weirder your lusts the
better and indulge them all the time
we're told that you should you should
give vent to all of your passions your
wrath your anger if you're if you're
feeling some kind of passion don't just
suppress it don't cultivate patience not
a spirit of resignation no no you gotta
let it out and you've especially got to
hate your parents and you've got to hate
the culture that you were raised in
because it's evil and terrible and
ultimately you should hate yourself and
you should you should not ever even
consider God as existing much less seek
a relationship with him that's all Huey
for a bunch of knuckle dragging cavemen
no no not you you're sophisticated you
just need to worship at the altar of
what the altar of our decade and culture
people have been taught this since
they're five years old is it any wonder
they turn out like Sam Brinton we got a
nation of Sam Brenton's that guy's Not
Unusual these days I mean it's it's
unusual you know we all look at him as
unusual
there was a survey that said that one in
five more than one in five Zoomers
identify as lgbtq identify as click
queer
Sam Brinton is increasingly becoming the
norm
and that's when something becomes the
norm that's not merely the fault of
individuals that's the fault of the
culture and of the society the rest of
the show continues now you do not want
to miss it if you're not a member click
the link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]